[Applause]
foreign
remember earlier this year I interviewed
California governor Gavin Newsom not
that long ago I floated the idea of a
policy-based debate you know Red versus
Blue uh Red State versus Blue State
between Gavin Newsom and Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis uh here's a
friendly reminder
I'll say Governor Newsom Governor
DeSantis
economy that's the only word I'm going
to throw out of it you minute minute
then you go at it next topic right and
I'll moderate it that way and you have
my word I'll moderate it that way I I'm
all in count on you you would do a
two-hour debate with Rhonda said I make
it three
wow
that would be uh how many of you would
like to see that would you like it okay
okay and this would be a debate that
highlights what our major political and
philosophical uh divides in this country
you know why is there Mass immigration
from Blue states to red ones how do you
reconcile a lot of these issues that are
so important you know states with high
income tax rates against states that
have uh low-income tax rates or none at
all like in the case of Florida uh
what's the difference between a
sanctuary State and State states that
actually respect immigration laws what
about the issue of America should we
remain energy independent or restrict
the use of fossil fuels altogether now
Vice President Harris recently turned
down the opportunity to debate Governor
DeSantis Gavin Newsom says he's not only
open to it he'll do it now we ask
Governor DeSantis we welcome him back to
the program Governor how are you
me great to have you
all right you heard Gavin make the offer
your answer is
absolutely I'm game let's get it done
just tell me when and where we'll do it
and here's the thing Sean I mean in in
one respect the um the debate between
California and Florida you know has
already been had as you suggest people
have been voting on that they've been
voting on it with their feet they have
fled California in record numbers
Florida has been the number one state
for net in migration we have the number
one ranked economy number one now in
education crime rate at a 50-year low
but in another sense this is the debate
for the future of our country because
you have people like Joe Biden they
would love to see the Californication of
the United States Biden may not even be
the nominee you could have Gavin Newsom
you could have Kamala Harris and I think
if we go down that direction that's
going to accelerate American decline we
can't see America decline anymore we
need to reverse American decline
Governor let me ask you because I know
this issue of of African-American
curriculum came up and my understanding
is that you had a panel of predominantly
African-American Scholars build out the
history of of slavery African-American
history in the country
um and you were attacked by Kamala
Harris over that
um and am I wrong in my understanding
that these were predominantly this this
curriculum was put together by
African-American Scholars predominantly
yeah exactly and one of the leaders was
the former chairman of the U.S
Commission on civil rights Kamala is
lying saying somehow these black
Scholars designed a curriculum to try to
say there was somehow good with slavery
that is not true they showed the
Injustice of slavery they told all the
stories throughout all of American
History including black history and
she's trying to demagogue it to score
political points but Sean we fight back
against that we do not bow down to the
media Mob We Don't bow down to the left
when they are trying to demagogue and
lie about things that are going on in
the State of Florida so I've stood up
for those black Scholars I thank them
for their job and they did a good job I
believe we're living in a time where
Democrats especially are trying to
criminalize political differences uh I
noticed a story about a Massachusetts
D.A wants the Attorney General Merrick
Garland to prosecute you for for sending
illegal immigrants to Martha's Vineyard
my understanding in that case by the way
they threw him off the island in less
than 24 hours and we did a background
check there were enough rooms for every
one of those illegal immigrants is it
true my understanding is is that every
person that went to Martha's Vineyard
signed a waiver and did so voluntarily
of course it was Sean I mean give me a
break what a farce that they're doing
what a Croc but it just shows you the
left in this country they want to
criminalize their political opposition
they want to weaponize the institutions
of government to go after people that
they can't beat through the political
process this was an issue in my
re-election Sean some people were
attacking me over the fact that we've
been very strong against illegal
immigration and what was the result of
that we won the greatest Republican
landslide in Florida gubernatorial
history so this is a Croc it's a total
abuse of power but it doesn't surprise
me that they would try to do that last
question I I noticed your response to
the indictment of President Trump
yesterday and I know your Rivals right
now but you said something that really
stuck with me and that is I don't
believe any Republican can get a fair
trial in Washington D.C or New York or
uh in Fulton County Georgia
should there be a better way to
administer Justice and not put
liberal Democrats in conservative
districts for trials it should be a
district where there is a a bare balance
of a jury pool
absolutely I mean in DC they will go
after you if you're Republican the facts
be damned Republicans don't have a fair
shot there they should be able to have a
fair trial somewhere else all right
Governor we're going to work on the
details behind the scenes with uh your
office and Governor Newsome's office we
appreciate you coming on and accepting
that challenge that'll be interesting TV
thank you for being with us hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else